so it's rare to say thanks someone man
and we were part of something where we
got to say thank you
oh yeah we all know that Samuel Adams
hitter that Sam Adams hitter dude they
have a toast on one campaign and you
might have seen Brennan probably posted
his on TF ATK so this is one that this
was my toast to everyone and I don't
drink but this campaign is awesome and
so what you guys to check it out this is
why I love your steel is like you have
to toast someone you know with a beer
which is not calling beverage but you're
sober and it takes real gangster to be
to be a comedian and stay sober when I
mean I'm a raging haha yeah but I've
didn't read before I became a comedian
Wow I drink double whiskey before every
set yeah so but here's what's gangster
in the discipline you have not even
entertainment it's really getting stir
dude so I'm proud of you man thanks man
appreciate it it's really courageous I
Knight
listen I it sucks sometimes I want that
beer I bet you do that [ __ ] is tasty god
I'm why hold on a summer day bro but the
thing about that you know I I know some
people who struggle with it and I think
your inspiration to them a lot of them
don't go out and like no I don't want be
tempted I'm telling me I'm be like Theo
be around it and have the willpower not
to entertainment it's really gangster
dude thanks bro I mean you get all
serious with a stupid turkey on my head
but let's play the app oh never take it
you see here yes but thank you bro yeah
this campaign was awesome man let's play
yeah let's play this OMA let's play it
being Theo von it's kind of wild right
now life's got pretty crazy it just kind
of blows my mind sometimes
I have an opportunist anyone that I want
I'm gonna toast the audience that comes
to my shows this next guy is one of my
favorite people in the whole world to
watch you see I don't drink alcohol but
I wanted to be part of this campaign
because toasting is such a simple act of
kindness letting somebody know that you
recognize them letting somebody know
that they mean something to you thank
you dude a lot of recognition these days
is liking something or sharing something
it's just so fleeting the value of that
but on the breaks let somebody know they
mean something to you
I've realized the other day I look like
somebody who knows where the rabies and
Sam Adams is the perfect beer for a
toast because it has a traditional vibe
to it I think my reincarnation bro you
know cuz I'm planning on doing it again
you know so often I feel like we could
advertise one thing but delivered
something else people deserve to get
something for their money you know I see
a couple sitting there maybe they hired
a babysitter
this is their one night of the month
that they go out and do something fun a
mother and son that will come out to the
show or a pair of brothers I want to
make a toast actually do you guys you
guys always continue to come back and
allow me to really follow my dream you
know like this is my dream for years how
we get to the venue and there wouldn't
be anybody there that's why it's
important to me to put on the best show
you know I couldn't live my dream so I'm
gonna toast you guys the audience for
always being there for me and meet me in
every city that I go to anybody can be
toasted it's something we need more of
telling each other hey I see and thank
them if your next beer is the Sam Adams
tonight is on me everybody in the house
and I thank you very
by Omaha
[Music]
how great is that man how cool is that
pretty cool you're the boys with Sam
Adams games buzz bhram gang game big bro
toast someone is pretty cool huh toast a
man who gets toasty out there toast your
bro man yeah that was cool
thanks but really cool man yeah yours is
really great too man it's alright no
it's awesome dude it's alright
you know there's gonna be associated Sam
Adams yeah and there's a neat group too
is just a neat group of people that got
to do it I thought it was pretty cool
the guy who shot a Kevin yeah he's smart
dude man yeah they did a good job
it was really cool they did a really
good job man sorry man this was in there
Jeff cool the comi story - yeah yeah I'm
not be what you don't know it's a
concert they really don't play those
games where they let you shoot and
cameras around like it's toughest place
in the world to shoot something yeah
it's like shooting Fort Knox yeah yeah
like Fantana just trying to shoot JFK
bro it's tough yeah I need some help I
saw yours before we played though I
haven't seen the finished product here
but man I think it's pretty badass man
that your cell burn you able to being
these comedy clubs around alcohol and
you're your buddy here's an alcohol like
I think it's because I don't drink it's
like yeah a lot of the audience drinks a
lot of fun dude my favorite drink is
cocaine man so that's why I don't drink
I don't have a problem drinking either
but if I drink dude there's a really
good chance on buck okay so I just can't
risk goes down to a bad road and with
that no risk Norton all the coke so
sorry that was a Sam I know who's Mei
brother cuz a breeze went by
[ __ ] I'll kill half a grand a
half a grandma [ __ ] tumeric from
[ __ ] sixty yards away sign [ __ ] I'll
put a spice rack on its knees
gonna be warmer tomorrow I'll be telling
you [ __ ] boy I got these crystal balls
up in here they do enough code doing
like freaking bread and stimmy do I keep
drinking
you keep snorting oh man we're gonna
enough in prison probably or it could be
awesome
well we're easily end up with probably
some charges or something for the song
no one ever did something creative
without cocaine or caffeine you feel me
no I don't feel that actually I don't
feel that either that's not the message
trying to give up and hopefully by us
doing this you can find when you're bros
and and give them a little cheer than
thankful man hey man yeah toast somebody
you care about you know Derrick ooh
probably my boy Brian Simpson
what am I just my boy man comic comedian
hey just funny
yeah just did your mom's house and we
started together the funniest man won't
open drawer oh just being just the best
like friend and just for being a [ __ ]
being a comedy friend just growing
through all this just grinding together
just coming up together no Steven happy
employees will see you might die it's
horrible oh yeah you can't breathe let
me sleep well you don't need Sam Adams
to do that okay I need a fat paycheck in
Sam Adams to do that yes you do it
that's the message cat who would you
toast uh I probably toast my dad mmm
nice does he drink beer oh my god like
hey Albert I can't drink really Papa cat
can dream of a beer belly no
surprisingly Shred City he he got Fred
City he should have yeah dad bought me
and her dad bought but he probably
should have a gut my grandpa has a gut
and it's hard as rocks amen that's what
my dad is gonna count the disease yet
yeah it is the disease called rockgut
it's called no arteriosclerosis Brendon
rockgut in the streets why would you
toast your dad though is he yeah how so
his life story is crazy my dance a
little [ __ ] flavor cat well my dad
escaped Vietnam lived in a refugee camp
for a year he would then he came to
America he somehow
hooked up with this chick from Mexico
who came at a front to a house party
from Mexico visiting family members he
somehow wooed her he didn't speak
English she didn't speak English they
got together he ended up moving to
Mexico for a year to be with her you
have kids with her uh we think he might
but we're not quite sure I'm sure I have
I got older older brother yeah Wow I'm
pretty sure I do
I don't know I wonder if your brother
watches the show or not but he has no
idea now what if your brothers and
sisters watch this thing your father had
then your father what came up here how
to meet your mom then uh
family friends and it's really weird
he's like 15 16 years older than her he
was a bit of a cradle-robber
mmm you dad has some game huh he's got
some game load that it's beautiful yeah
badass dude mm-hmm
I like that yeah I mean yeah I just
toasted the audience a lot of those
people come out and have a great time
and it's you know it's just crazy to
have an audience I mean it's so hard to
get an audience in this business or get
people to have it's so hard I mean yeah
it's tough at least 16 17 years whoo
yeah yeah I always forget I said this
the other day were at the Comedy Store
you walked away and I said something
about just comedy in general someone was
like dude Thea's been doing it for 15
years see I always feel like I don't I
don't know why I don't know I feel like
we just we do it the same ya know yeah
man I mean I was on the two hours time
I've been touring for probably it's
almost 16 years now so yeah I think
that's why this past year I just got I
just this is one of the toughest years
ever has been great but it's also it was
just a lot it was just like man I just
hit this spot time where I was just so
tight I was just exhausted almost
overwhelmed right in the stimulus it's a
lot just overwhelmed a lot and I think
it's tough for people to understand I
get it in you not talk about something I
think people think because you're Theo
van you have this you know you're torn
on time sold-out crowds and your pipes
going well they think oh do you have
money it's good it's like it's not about
Aimee of that man yeah it's not that
doesn't equal happiness yeah I don't
have anything different I got a Jeep
Grand Cherokee now that I got a you know
paying 550 a month on but that's about
it man a nice thing I bought these hair
plugs that [ __ ] the fresh [ __ ] baby
drape I'm growing yeah it does look
fresh
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]